in this video you're going to learn how
to graph rational functions step by step
by step and this is designed to be a
complete guide so if you're new to
graphing rational functions or something
that you've been struggling with let's
dive into three important examples each
one's gonna be a little bit different to
help you really understand how to do
this so the first example number one we
have y equals x minus 1 over x squared
minus 2x minus 3 so these are called
rational functions because you can see
now you have a polynomial divided by
another polynomial it's a ratio right
like a fraction but the first thing that
you're going to want to do is you're
going to factor this as much as you can
the numerator and the denominator so
here what we're gonna do is the
numerator we really can't factor we're
gonna leave that as X minus 1 the
denominator though we can factor this as
X minus 3 times X plus 1 if you need to
review factoring check out my learn how
to factor video but this is factored now
so what you want to do next is you want
to look first to see if there's any
holes in the graph they're called holes
or removable discontinuities basically
what it is it's like a missing point ok
like that and when you graph it on a
graphing calculator you won't
necessarily see this point because it's
just like infinitesimally small it's
like a you know just like a pixel right
and the way that you know if you have a
hole is if there's a factor in the
numerator that cancels with a factor in
the denominator we're gonna look at an
example like that coming up but in this
case you can see there's not a factor in
the numerator that cancels with a factor
in the denominator so there's no holes
we're just gonna write none ok now we're
gonna go do the vertical asymptotes now
the vertical asymptotes you're gonna
want to look at the denominator and you
want to set these factors equal to zero
so if we say X minus 3 equals zero and
we add 3 to both sides you can see x
equals 3 and if we set X plus 1 equal to
zero you can see that x equals negative
1 now really if you think about it X
cannot be negative 1 because negative 1
plus 1 is 0 0 times this factor will be
0 and you can't divide by zero and
that's why we get vertical asymptotes by
setting these factors in the denominator
equal to 0 because we really don't want
the diameter to be 0 so I like to kind
of graph as I go through this as I go
through the different steps so let's go
ahead and graph the verdict
asymptote x equals negative 1 remember x
equals lines are vertical lines and x
equals 3 which is right here okay it's a
- our dotted line you won't actually see
the lines on the graph you're just going
to see that the grass going to get
closer and closer to those lines but not
cross them or touch them okay the next
thing is to look at whether there's a
horizontal asymptote or a slant
asymptote it can't be both it's gonna be
one or the other and the way that you
analyze the horizontal asymptotes is you
want to look at the highest degree term
in the numerator and the highest degree
term in the denominator what I mean by
that is you want to look at these
exponents see how this is like X to the
first and this is X to the second power
you want to analyze those highest power
terms in the numerator in the
denominator now if the denominators
degree is higher than the numerators
highest degree then the horizontal
asymptote is going to be y equals 0 if
it's a tie between these two degrees
let's say there are both two or they
both to the third degree then it's going
to be the ratio of the coefficients in
front of those variables and then the
third case is if the degree in the
numerator is higher by one than the
degree in the denominator you're gonna
get a slant asymptote like a diagonal
asymptote and we're gonna look at all
three of those cases in these three
example problems so stay tuned for the
next couple examples but in this case y
equals zero remember y equals lines are
horizontal lines y equals zero is
actually going to be right on the x-axis
I'll just write over here y equals zero
okay now we've got the y intercept in
the X intercepts so these are kind of
like some key points that are you know
easy to find and good to help you get a
good graph so what I like to do with
these ones is just think of making like
a table like this if you set X equal to
0 that's going to give you your y
intercept and if you set y equal to 0
that's going to give you your x
intercept so let's go ahead and put 0 &
4 accent sometimes I like to go back to
the original problem before we factored
it if you put 0 in for X that's going to
cancel out this term this term and this
term so you're really going to be just
left with negative 1 over negative 3
which those two negatives cancel and
that gives you 1/3 so 0 comma 1/3 is
going to be right here on the y axis
now the x-intercept we have to set the Y
variable equal to zero that's over here
but one thing that you kind of notice is
that the only way that Y would be equal
to zero is if the numerator is equal to
zero and the denominator is not equal to
zero but basically just set the
numerator to zero because if you have
like zero over something that's not zero
right like that that fraction is going
to be equal to zero that means y equals
zero so we're just going to set the
numerator to zero X minus one equals
zero
that's going to be x equals one when you
add 1 to both sides so that means this
is going to cross right here at one
comma zero so basically you're setting
the opposite variable equal to zero what
some students like to do like if that
part was a little confusing to you is
again just put 0 in for Y so this would
be like 0 equals X minus 1 over x
squared minus 2x minus 3 0 is like 0
over 1 and what you can do is you can
cross multiply if you know the cross
product property X minus 1 times 1 is
itself and this times 0 is just 0 so
then if you add 1 to both sides x equals
1 so that's your x-intercept so just two
different ways to look at it and then
the last part is to plot additional
points to get a good graph now what I
like to do here is see you can cross a
horizontal asymptote that's no problem
you can cross it a vertical asymptote
you cannot cross or touch because you
would be dividing by 0 and that's
undefined but what happens is because
you can't cross these vertical
asymptotes when you approach it from the
left side or from the right side it's
either going to go up like this or it's
going to go down like that so either up
towards positive infinity down towards
negative infinity it's basically like a
brick wall you can't go through it
you're either gonna have to turn like
that or turn like that so what I
recommend doing is picking some points
on either side of the vertical
asymptotes and you can do this one of
two ways you can do what they call sine
analysis which I'm going to show you in
this video or you can just go ahead and
just plot some points but let me show
you so let's say for example if you were
to take negative 2 so negative 2 I'm
gonna put it into this factored form
right here negative 2 minus 1 is
negative 3 okay which I'm just gonna I'm
just going to write this as an egg
okay because it came out two negative
three and then over here negative 2
minus 3 is negative 5 so I'm gonna write
negative and negative 2 plus 1 is
negative 1 I'm just gonna write negative
a negative times a negative is a
positive and a negative divided by
positive is a negative right so what
that means is that when you're
approaching from this side okay over
here at negative 2 it's going to be
negative meaning it's going to go down
towards a negative infinity so I'm just
going to draw an arrow like that and I
can tell that this graph is going to
approach this horizontal asymptote see
on the x-axis like that so that gives us
a pretty good idea what the graph looks
like
again you can plot additional points but
our main concern is whether it's going
down as it approaches this vertical
asymptote or whether it's going up
towards positive infinity
okay now let's pick a point on this side
of the vertical asymptote I'm gonna pick
like negative 0.9 so I'll just write
that down negative 0.9 so if we put
negative 0.9 and the numerator that's
going to be negative one point nine
which is just negative negative one
negative point nine minus three is
negative three point nine that's
negative and negative point nine plus
one is a positive point one right so
that comes out to a negative and a
negative times a positive is a negative
and a negative divided by a negative is
a positive that tells us that we're
we're over here at negative point nine
this is going up towards positive
infinity and you can probably tell that
because you see these points going like
this it's it's gonna go like this right
okay now let's pick some points on
either side of this vertical asymptote
maybe like two point nine now so if I
put two point nine and here two point
nine minus one is going to give us a
positive value two point nine minus
three is going to give us a negative
value and two point nine plus one is
going to give us a positive value so
here we get a positive a negative times
a positive is a negative but a positive
divided by a negative is a negative
which means this is going down towards
negative infinity but we probably
already knew that just based on these
couple points here the last one is to
pick over here just to the right of this
vertical asymptote maybe here at three
point one or we could even just do four
so if we put four in
let's see that's 4 minus 1 which is 3
that's positive and 4 minus 3 is 1
that's positive and 4 plus 1 is 5 that's
positive so positive I by positive is a
positive and that means that when you're
approaching from this side it's going up
towards positive infinity as you go out
here towards the right it's approaching
that x-axis that horizontal asymptote y
equals 0 and we've got a pretty good
sketch of the graph so let's go and do
some more challenging examples ok number
two see if you can do this problem on
your own so we've got y equals x squared
minus 16 all over 2x squared plus 7x
minus 4 so what's the first step well
the first step is you want to factor it
as much as you can the numerator is a
difference of two squares two perfect
squares X plus 4 X minus 4 and the
denominator is a trinomial with a
leading coefficient that's not equal to
one so this one is going to factor like
this so 8 X minus 1 X is 7 X okay so
know what you want to do is you want to
analyze it to see if there are any holes
in the graph and remember the holes
occur when there's a factor in the
numerator that cancels the factor in the
denominator which is exactly what we
have here we've got X plus 4 X plus 4
but to find the location of that hole
what you want to do is you want to set X
plus 4 equal to 0 solve for X that's
negative 4 and then if you take negative
4 and put it back into what's left over
in that equation that'll give us our y
coordinate of our hole so if we do that
we get negative 4 minus 4 which is
negative 8 negative 4 times 2 is
negative 8 minus 1 is negative 9 the two
negatives cancel so we're getting
negative 4 comma 8 9 so that's going to
be let's see right here 1 2 3 4 and 8
ninths is going to be right about here
okay so now let's go to the vertical
asymptotes so the vertical asymptotes
remember you cannot divide by zero so by
setting these factors in the denominator
equal to zero but not this one because
remember this one was where our hole was
okay you're gonna find the vertical
asymptote so here we've got two X minus
one is equal to zero add 1 to both sides
and divide by 2
so you can see X cannot equal 1/2 and
that's going to be our vertical
asymptote 1/2 is right here okay
x equals 1/2 and again remember this one
can't you be a vertical asymptote it's
either going to be a hole or a vertical
asymptote it can't be both it's one or
the other of course X cannot be negative
four but again we saw that as a
removable point so for letter C now we
hadn't want to analyze whether it's a
horizontal asymptote or a slant
asymptote so here what we do is we zero
in on the highest degree term in the
numerator the highest degree term in the
denominator and notice it's a tie these
are both x squared so when it's a tie
like that you want to look at the ratio
of the coefficient in front of those
terms that's 1 over 2 that's going to be
y equals 1/2 which is going to be right
here now you might be saying Mario I
don't understand why is it the ratio of
the coefficients well what you can think
of is that when you go to the right end
of the graph or the left end of the
graph meaning as X gets large or larger
or what our X gets smaller and smaller
towards negative infinity or X
approaches positive infinity the
negative 16 the negative 4 doesn't
change the 7x is not growing as fast as
x squared so what happens is you can do
this on your calculator putting a large
value for X like maybe like a hundred or
then maybe try a thousand and what
you'll notice is it because these terms
are growing much faster than these terms
as X is bigger and bigger it's really
just going to look like 1 X well over 2
x squared 1 x squared over 2 x squared
the X words are going to cancel and
you're gonna just be left with y equals
1/2 and you can just do that experiment
you'll see that that's approaching 1/2
as X gets really large positive or a
really large negative number okay so now
for the Y intercepts and the X
intercepts what you want to do is you
want to make a table you want to set X
equal to 0 to find the y intercept and y
equal to 0 to find the x intercept so
it's kind of like saying the opposite
variable equal to 0 so here if we put 0
in for X is going to cancel this term
this term in this term leaving us with
negative 16 over negative 4 which is
positive 4 so at 0 4 right here that's
our y-intercept and by setting y equal
to 0 we can solve for the x intercept
remember I showed you that shortcut
where if you make y 0 that's only going
to be possible if these factors in the
numerator are equal to zero so by
setting X minus 4 equal to zero we get x
equals 4 and this one we already
cancelled out over here so this is just
going to be over here at 1 2 3 4 and
that's your x-intercept now again I just
wanted to show you when these factors
cancel like this the basic graph is
going to be just like the graph of y
equals x minus 4 over 2x minus 1 with
the exception of there just being this
missing point that removable point okay
now we just want to plot some additional
points as needed to get a good graph
here and again remember our little
strategy we said if we can pick some
points on either side of the vertical
asymptote to figure out whether the
graph is going up towards positive
finding or down towards negative
infinity that will be a big help but
here for this one you can see that the
graph is going like this and like this
right so we've already got that branch
of the graph over here let's just verify
let's maybe pick x equals 1 1 minus 4 is
negative 3 negative and 2 times 1 is 2
minus 1 is positive 1 that's positive
and negative I by a positive is a
negative so that tells us over here at 1
this is going to be approaching negative
infinity so you can see that the graphs
gonna look something like that and you
got it ok number 3 you see if you can do
this one on your own this is also a
unique example different from the other
two that we've covered so far in this
video we've got y equals x cubed plus x
squared minus 2x all over x squared plus
2x minus 8 and before I jump into this
problem I just want to mention if you
like my teaching style be sure to check
out my video courses I've got courses
for algebra 1 algebra 2 a CT math SAT
Math go ahead and check out those
courses but let's dive into this example
now we've got the first thing is to
factor right so you can see you can
factor out an X on all out of all these
so that's going to be x squared plus X
minus 2 and then you can factor this
part here a little bit further into X
plus 2 and X minus 1 so now the
denominator is fairly easy to factor
this is just going to be X plus
for an X minus 2 so the first step is to
analyze are there any holes in the graph
are there any factors in the numerator
that cancel with any factors in the
denominator in this case there's not so
we're just gonna say no holes okay for
vertical asymptotes now we want to look
at the denominators remember we can't
divide by zero so by sending these
factors to zero we find our vertical
asymptotes so x equals negative 4 and x
equals 2 or our vertical asymptotes
let's draw those in so this is x equals
negative 4 and x equals positive 2 looks
like that now we want to analyze the
horizontal asymptote or the slant
asymptote and how can we tell well I
like to go back to the original equation
and you want to zero in on those highest
degree terms in the numerator and the
highest degree term in the denominator
when the degree in the numerator is one
degree higher than the degree in the
denominator that tells us that there's
gonna be a slant asymptote now you're
probably saying Mario how do I find the
equation of the slant asymptote and you
would do that by doing long division
polynomial long division so let's go
ahead and do that so we're trying to see
how many times is x squared plus 2x
minus 8 go into X cubed plus x squared
minus 2x
so x squared goes into X cubed x times
if we distribute we get X cubed plus 2x
squared minus 8x we subtract or you can
change the signs to the opposite and add
because subtraction is like adding the
opposite and this comes out to is that
6x and then let's see how many times
does x squared go into negative x
squared that's negative 1 times if we
distribute we get negative x squared
minus 2x plus 8 and if we subtract or
change the signs to the opposite we get
8x minus 8 now notice this degree is
lower than this degree this is our
remainder you'd have to worry about the
remainder if you need help with the long
division check out my video on doing
polynomial long division and I'll go
over that in that video
but you can see this is really going to
be y equals x minus 1 is our slant
asymptote so the y intercept is going to
be negative 1 and the slope is 1 so what
this is going to be starting here it's
gonna be going up 1 over 1 so it looks
something like that
ok okay I'm just gonna erase this so it
doesn't get in the way of our of our
graph as we proceed okay okay so now
what we want to do is look at the x
intercept in the y intercept remember we
do that by making a table and setting X
to 0 and then sending Y to 0 so by
sending X to 0 it's going to cancel out
all these terms except for this one so
it's going to be 0 over negative 8 which
is just 0 so it's going right here
through the origin at 0 0 and if we set
a Y to 0 okay remember the only way that
y is going to be 0 is if the factors in
the numerator is 0 because 0 divided by
anything that's not 0 is 0 we've already
taken this one to account 0 but it could
also be negative 2 and positive 1 I'm
just setting these factors in the
numerator to 0 so I'm just going to
write negative 2 or 1 so let's see it's
going to cross right here at negative 2
and here at positive 1 okay this is a
pretty challenging graph so now what we
want to do is we want to plot some
additional points and what I need to do
is pick points on either side of the
vertical asymptotes because we want to
see if the graph is going up towards
positive fitty or down towards negative
infinity so let's start over here at
negative 5 so let's see so negative 5 if
I put negative 5 in here I get a
negative times a negative times a
negative all over negative times a
negative so that comes out to 3 negative
is a negative 2 negative is a positive
negative divided by positive is a
negative so that tells us is going down
towards negative infinity so you can see
this graphs looking something like that
it's approaching the slant asymptote
okay now let's approach this vertical
asymptote from this side so let's maybe
put in negative 3 if we put in negative
3 we get an
native native 3 plus 2 is negative 1
that's negative negative 3 minus 1 is
negative 4 that's negative negative 3
plus 4 is possible and that's positive
negative 3 minus 2 is negative 5 that's
negative so here we get 3 negatives
multiplies to a negative a positive
times a negative is a negative a
negative a negative is a positive
see how we're just analyzing the signs
it's not so important the number I mean
you could get the number and then plot
that point precisely but the main thing
is I want to figure out this is positive
it's going up towards positive infinity
so I'm just going to draw an arrow like
that and so now what happens here well
let's go now to this vertical asymptote
let's pick one point nine and two point
one so just on either side so if I pick
one point nine here that's gonna be
positive right this is gonna be positive
this is gonna be positive this is gonna
be positive this is going to be negative
so we have a positive divided by a
negative which is a negative which tells
us that this is going down like this
let's go from this side here let's pick
maybe when I say two point one so let's
see if so for two point one see we need
some space here how about up here two
point one so two point one we get a
positive two point one plus 2 is
positive two point one minus one is
positive this is positive and this is
positive so you can see this is gonna be
positive or positive which is positive
so that means this is going up towards
positive infinity right there so this
branch you can see it's basically going
something like this approaching that
slant asymptote well what happens in
here well you can see that and you can
plot some additional points here too
like I might put in maybe like like a
half and maybe like negative one but
what you're gonna see is this graphs
actually gonna go like this and you got
it now
some people will ask me to say well how
did you know to been right there like
why didn't you go away up here and they
weighed and then way down here and like
that
well you can like I said plot some
additional points when you get to
calculus you're gonna be able to find
this exact point where the graph bends
but at this point we're just getting a
pretty good graph just using the sine
analysis and
some key points the other thing you
might be asking is Oh Mario I notice you
cross the slant asymptote well it's okay
to cross a horizontal or a slant
asymptote it's just that when you get to
the ends of the graph you know it's
going to gradually approach that
asymptote as opposed to crossing yet but
you know near the middle okay it can it
can cross and that's completely okay
you just can't cross these vertical
asymptotes and again remember that's
because you can't divide by zero if you
want to see more examples
follow me over to that video right there
and we'll dive into some more of these
types of examples I'll see you in that
video